today we're playing on the world's most
tilted table trying out green screen
suits matched with different balls airml
extended hands let's get into it what
kind of special day it is today that we
just hit one billion views so if you've
ever watched our video thank you what's
the issue of today the issue is that the
table is too stable so we have to tilt
it I feel like I'm very short and here
I'm very tall
I feel like I can't miss because
the table was going like up in that
corner
the table still isn't quite weird enough
how many uh degrees is it tilted now
[Music]
it's weird because I can't see the ball
it's like Top Spin it's now under Spin
and stuff so something weird is
happening but other than that it's
surprisingly normal still Hotel thing oh
yeah 40 degrees
all right
next
[Music]
try and get that one I will
oh I'll try to get that one
okay long distance serve
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
okay this one was a great challenge if
you guys have more great challenges like
this let us know in the comments come on
to the next one all right we have a
green screen we have some costumes let's
see if we can distract our opponents
open your eyes in three two one open oh
my God
what are you
people girl it's very pretty but it
didn't distract you it didn't know
yeah
oh my God he's a party tourist oh my God
oh my gosh it will be worth it you can
directly look at what's waiting for you
oh I've been thinking about this for a
long time will you marry me of course
awesome we started off the the marriage
with uh with a rally and a win he won
his heart and you won the rally exactly
[Music]
have you ever seen a sheep play like
this
is the best part
man come on stage make whenever you're
ready open your eyes
[Music]
Jurassic Park or something
whoa what is sure
one go
okay like a Halloween thing
okay
you sort of did it was super
underwhelming but I still got distracted
it was fun seeing all the different next
challenge we're gonna do the knit roller
serve the idea is to serve a bowl so
that the ball rolls on the net and we're
gonna try to make it look so that it
rolls on just one net from the angle but
it's still very difficult I think this
should take like maybe a few hundred
attempts okay and if I make this you
gotta subscribe
[Music]
should School
we have a camera facing AML and Emil can
see himself on that screen and we'll see
if he'll be able to play no look this is
so messed up yes sir okay let's try
like you can put the hand in the right
place but the depth is the problem I
haven't got a single oh
yeah
this other way around
[Music]
oh nice don't be afraid of Mika I'm not
afraid
[Music]
this might actually work
he almost feels like this is one of the
hardest things that we have tried let me
do like
no we just need to get that off the tree
yeah
[Music]
because it doesn't help
match the Five Points this point with a
different ball first up the mini ping
pong ball
[Music]
there's some kind of purple
he was trying to kill me on that one
[Music]
how's that supposed to work you figure
it out it's awesome
that was a fun one I quite enjoyed that
bouncy ball directly to the faster one
foreign
[Music]
volleyball two touches
the Mega Ball
now I continue with this one deciding
points
[Music]
yeah it's it's perfect tape a paddle to
your one hand it's a good grip fingeries
as well the right way it's actually
quite a bit heavier there's a new player
in the hall airmel extension hands
no look at that
[Music]
oh
oh yeah
Drop shots
it doesn't help so much with this
like acceleration there again
look at that okay let's do a chop
[Applause]
oh topspin foreign
[Music]
next the big hand smash swim smash
thank you
that deserves to subscribe I did this
for like one and a half hours or
something
I'm not sure I'm sure it's over leaves I
want to get out of the art of this no no
no
or five more